this video sponsored by black desert
online black desert online a sandbox
oriented fantasy MMORPG with a
beautifully designed open-world and
crisp HD graphics it features real-time
action based combat and an amazingly
detailed character creation system with
various diverse classes to choose from
each having unique skills and abilities
shai black desert online 18th class is a
unique addition to the popular MMORPG
as it's the first character that focuses
on support abilities and life skills
check out the link in the description
for a 7-day trial if you'd like to try
out the game the much-awaited a second
season of one punch man's hit the
airwaves and we just can't get enough of
it however with the season coming to an
end some people ask the question now
what fear not for our video today we'll
be going over ten shows that we
recommend to people who like one punch
man these shows have different
approaches in telling their story but
they all contain an elemental to that
people who follow saitama's adventures
can all appreciate let's get started
[Music]
let's kick off the list with our number
10 entry problem children are coming
from another world aren't they
unexpectedly we start off this list with
an Easter Kai show that existed years
before the rest of its kin began taking
over anime problem children in essence
is some sort of prototype of no game no
life a series where people are taken
from the real world and dropped into a
world full of games both this show and
one punch man star a main protagonist
who has immeasurable power while the
emcee in the anime in Saitama have
differences in personality and approach
the former being cocky while the latter
generally leaning towards being bored
and lazy both are essentially
overpowered characters that continue to
seek stronger opponents if you're into
that type of character light novel
elements and something similar to no
game no life this show could be to your
liking
[Music]
Tiger and bunny makes its foothold on
the ninth spot a world where being a
heroes of business and the heroes of
ranked and evaluated based on
performance are we talking about one
punch man or tiger and bunny tiger and
bunny features a commercialized model of
organizing and ranking superheroes as
they're sponsored and treated like
reality TV stars when it comes down to
it though tiger and bunny may not have
the same over-the-top action that one
punch man has but it more than makes up
for it with showing us another and in my
opinion more interesting side of the
superhero as a career story
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
to be hero makes its way to number eight
on the list one possible product of
OPM's popularity is to be hero a show
featuring a perverted toilet seat
designer who gained superpowers and
becomes a hero
the catch is turned into an ugly fat ass
who gets promptly thrown out of his home
by his own daughter who actually no
longer recognizes him like one punch man
to be hero features comedy and has an
over-the-top atmosphere but in contrast
it's full of toilet humor and slapstick
comedy the crass humor might not be
something that everyone enjoys if you
get past that one can enjoy to be hero
for what it is a fun parody of the
superhero genre sweeping past the
competition haven't you heard I'm
Sakamoto takes the number seven spot on
the list perhaps it's not just me who
thought of one punch man upon first
seeing this anime their primary genres
are different yet I find the two shows
extremely similar due to their approach
in their lead characters while one punch
man revolves around a superhero who's
too strong for his own good haven't you
heard I'm Sakamoto is a comedy about a
character who has no shortage of
coolness good looks
intelligence sophistication swag you
name it no matter how much the other
envious boys in school plot and scheme
nothing seems to unnerve Sakamoto
he always foils their plans and
continues to breeze through high school
life with his signature flawless flare
both shows might be a long way from each
other in terms of the main genre but the
overarching themes of a flawlessly
hilariously overcoming everything with
ease is there I'm sure that those who
enjoyed one punch man for showcasing an
overly powerful hero would enjoy
watching the magnificent Sakamoto
[Music]
assassination classroom is number six on
the list I take it you may have seen the
picture of a smiling yellow tentacle
monster somewhere before the said
monster called korosensei starts off
destroying part of the moon in
assassination classroom
he then threatens the earth and it's up
to the students of class 3e to stop him
how you might ask by assassinating him
within one year of course is such a
tasks not easy for students not if you
have to deal with a homeroom teacher who
is accelerated regeneration SuperSpeed
and a plethora of superpowers
assassination classrooms just like one
punch man in the sense that they both
have powerful characters who are
hell-bent on finding someone who can
match their prowess korosensei is ever
developing relationship with his
students is a joy to watch he teaches
not only academics but also life lessons
to the point that at times you forget
that this likeable teacher is the one
who's responsible for the end of the
world as we know it the series is
brimming with a good dose of action
comedy and drama it may not be about
superheroes fighting the forces of evil
but fans of one punch man will likely
show a lot
Overlord takes the fifth spot on the
list at first glance it's not too
difficult to see why the tale of Aegis
ilds powerful dark wizard who seeks to
take over the world would end up on the
list of recommendations for people who
love one-punch man despite carrying
completely different aesthetics and
overall tone overlord has won a major
thing in common with one punch man the
presence of an overwhelmingly strong
protagonist who's completely unstoppable
the main difference is that one punch
man has predominantly comedic elements
while overlord is more story-driven
ion's is also more serious compared to
Saitama and has a completely different
moral compass if you enjoyed one punch
man overlord just might have the
elements that you fancy while delivering
a tale in a different manner and style
don't let the drastic differences in
tone and aesthetic dissuade you want
punch man fans overlords the series you
don't want to miss sitting at fourth
place is the disastrous life of psyche
Kay but most people power is a blessing
that anyone would die for that's not the
case though for psyche he finds the
various assortment of powers nothing
more than a bother not only that his
powers attract attention giving him
great difficulty in getting the quiet
and peaceful life that he Oso desires
both the disastrous life of psyche Kay
and one punch man deal with the idea of
power as a curse it's a bothersome thing
that only serves to complicate one's
life and render all exciting challenges
irrelevant if you want to show this as
funny as one punch man and focuses on
the downside of having power the
disastrous life of psyche Kay may be
your cup of tea it might not have as
much action as one punch man but the
show will still leave you in stitches
with its comedy
[Music]
we begin the top three on our list with
my hero academia now I feel that my hero
academia is the one show that has
reached the status that it's shown in
jump for runners had in the mid-2000s
most people probably don't need an
in-depth introduction to deku story but
there's no way that this amazing show
should miss the list of recommendations
for people who enjoyed one punch man the
actions they're the world where being a
superhero is a professions they're the
hero associations are there the colorful
cast of characters are there so what
else could you ask for one punch man
does have a protagonist that starts out
strong but my hero academia is probably
your best bet for something similar with
a classic shown in backdrop if you want
to try a superhero series where the
protagonist aims to overcome challenges
in order to become the world's greatest
hero feel free to start your journey
into the world of my hero academia trust
me it's gonna be one hell of a
rollercoaster ride
[Music]
number two on the list is none other
than Quintana who could forget the gold
standard for shown in comedy Gintama
gonzales a series that's carved its own
reputation of being a shown in series
that can quickly whiplash from serious
to hilarious it also has a cast of
quirky characters that look at home in
the story that the series is trying to
tell then pass the abundance of comedic
parodies in Gintama ly serious arcs that
tell epic stories I'm sure that fans of
one punch man can appreciate such a
storytelling method catching up to
Gintama is a gargantuan task but don't
let it discourage you from trying it out
if you haven't done so because it's well
worth the time
what else did you expect at number one
of course we have mob psycho 100 as the
number one show on our list if you like
one punch man then by all means you'll
probably enjoy the anime adaptation of
one's other web manga the series that
revolves around mob and his mission of
exercising evil spirits has garnered
popularity since its introduction and
has spawned a sequel that recently
concluded as expected mob psycho and one
punch man share a similar aesthetic both
have absurd over-the-top action aboard
an overpowered lead character and comedy
even the leads relationship to other
characters on one show can be considered
foils - the ones from the other show
it's no surprise that people have been
calling mob psycho one punch man with
ghosts or an interesting note the two
shows have also done their fair share of
cross referencing each other as well
while the two universes aren't actually
connected one punch man in mob psycho
are probably as close to one another as
two shows could possibly be if you enjoy
one then I guarantee that you'll
definitely enjoy the other
[Music]
baccala fight data
[Music]
so what do you think of this list then
for those who want to help fellow
one-punch man fans out feel free to
either chime in about your favorite show
on the list or something else that you
recommend don't forget to check out our
sponsors game black desert online I'll
leave the link in the description I'll
see you next time on Vinnie tube
[Music]